[Music]
so what are we gonna learn today
we're gonna talk about the three
products that make up APM stackdriver
tres stackdriver debugger stackdriver
profiler with a high-level demo perhaps
an announcement and then Nate's gonna
come up to talk about how he uses this
outfit seven to make meaningful changes
so before we get started I just want to
learn a little bit about the audience so
how many of you guys consider yourselves
developers have a developer title and
how many more on the operators side how
many are both and and how many of those
hold the title sre or something similar
to that awesome good good bunch now as
far as stackdriver goes who's familiar
with stackdriver
and who uses stackdriver in production
today awesome great so we got a lot of
usage so we'll make this really quick
but for those who didn't have their hand
up sack driver is Google clouds
observability sweet so we try to make
google the most observable cloud as much
as possible and help you learn more
about what's happening your environment
so you can resolve problems quicker and
make meaningful performance changes
reduce cost and just you know overall
help to run a the best system you can
with the best possible information and
our job is really to help you guys help
your customers to make that a reality
so the stackdriver portfolio consists of
four main tools our main groups of tools
there's monitoring logging a p.m. and
IRM IRM is our newest Incident Response
Management we're talking about 8:00 p.m.
today which is application performance
monitoring and it's meant to be using
context of everything else APM gives you
part of the story that deeper level of
debug information however we do want to
make sure that you also have that paired
with metrics for good statistically
relevant data and logs for that more
traditional troubleshooting style
information so from a high-level
perspective let's talk about APM as I
mentioned there are three products on
the suite trace profiler and debugger
traces are distributed tracing product
now who here has heard of distributed
tracing who's from
probably the same people who put up
their hands for stackdriver and how many
people are using distributed tracing in
production today awesome and keep your
hand up if you're using stack drivers
trace okay cool
so for those who didn't have their hand
out distributed tracing helps you to
visualize the request as it flows
through your Virant this is especially
important in micro service based
applications and the goal is to help you
determine the root cause faster analyze
trends and understand your topology and
how your services call each other and
ultimately to make meaningful changes as
I mentioned before so to illustrate this
here's an example of what an application
architecture could look like you have
your users connecting to your load
balancer which sends traffic to the
front-end multiple back-end services
perhaps compartmentalized not monolithic
applications as things once were and
that can that communicates to multiple
back-end platform services such as
databases analytics layers data
warehouses etc however today things look
a little bit more like this where things
are more chaotic and we're talking about
hundreds if not thousands of small micro
services working together for a common
goal and this is where tracing comes in
shining a light on the path that your
requests take through the system so that
you can troubleshoot problems a heck of
a lot easier if you can only see one
very small part of an overall picture
it's quite difficult to understand the
root cause of a problem context matters
flow matters and tracing helps you
understand that full path so without
further ado we're gonna do a brief demo
of stack driver trace and we'll start
here on the overview tab so here in the
overview tab you can understand your
most common requests your URIs your RPC
calls and their associated latency plus
a shot a snapshot of your last analysis
report but most the magic is actually in
the trace waterfall view now for those
of you familiar with stackdriver you'll
see that this UI looks a little bit
different this is actually something
that we've recently launched to alpha if
you're interested reach out to me Brian
Zimmerman at Google calm but I am with a
why we'd love to have you have you
joined it looks a little bit different
in the past but the goal is still the
same that you can use these filter terms
to really
find the trace that you're trying to
find that helps you identify the problem
you're trying to troubleshoot now once
you find a trace you simply select it
from the list and you can see it pop up
in the waterfall view below so each of
these bars are basically a span and what
we call a short there what we call a
span and a span is effectively a call to
a service so the root span encompasses
the entire request and every child span
is a downstream service that that
request calls so you can understand that
flow here we've got an overall request
that's quite long there's lots of calls
and a lot of them if you if you look are
very similar it's calling get product
which calling get product again there's
a lot of repetition here we're not quite
sure why off to the right hand side it's
even more apparent that you have an
overall trace time of 31,000
milliseconds which is obviously not
acceptable by any user but 29,000
milliseconds of that total is actually
caused by these 14 calls to the get
product so this is obviously the cause
of the problem and what we need to
troubleshoot and you can understand how
this will might be difficult to surmise
without a product like trace each one of
these calls isn't by itself wrong and
isn't by itself horribly long but when
you put them together their overall
impact of the whole is substantial and
really the root cause of what is a
significant user facing issue once you
identify which is the which is the
service you're interested in you can
click on it to get more contextual
information correlate with log data look
at event data and you can actually send
custom timed or not time to annotations
that show up in the service now on while
we're on this subject from an
instrumentation perspective we actually
recommend you adopt open census my
colleague Morgan has a talk on Thursday
to talk about that exhaustively so we
won't have time to go into it today but
that's a talk that I would definitely
attend lots of great information the
analysis reports gives you more of an
understanding of things from a trend
perspective so in addition to
understanding that particular trace that
one little request if I want to
understand
know what's happening overall with my
service what is chains in a major or
minor way that might be affecting my
users experience even if it's not
immediately apparent to me the analysis
report does the math to bring it to the
surface and those can either be done on
demand or automatically in this
particular example report we can see
that you know the high-end 99th
percentile latency is great but for some
reason my 50th percentile latency which
is the general case for performance or
the general case for my users experience
is double what it used to be right so
that's that's obviously a problem and
you can see that in the percentile
groupings below and you can actually
even drill into example traces to
understand what exactly is happening in
that instance for that report and that
gives you a high level view of trace and
we're gonna move to the next product in
our suite so how these fit together is
they are designed to work as a team of
course trace helps you get from problem
to service profiler which Morgan will
talk about helps you get from service to
method and debugger which is the third
product helps you get from method to the
actual problem that you're seeing and it
does this by allowing you to take a
debug information on the fly so without
a tool like this if I have a problem I
might look at the logs try to understand
what's happening stare at the code a bit
come up with a theory and maybe I have
the log lines that I need but more
likely I have to add a debug module or
some additional logging then I have to
deploy that perhaps restart the service
then I'm gonna wait for the problem to
happen again search the logs and repeat
on and on until I understand the problem
well with debugger because you can take
snapshots to inspect local variables and
add log lines in production safely
without restarting without redeploying
you can tighten that troubleshooting
flow quite a bit your lengthy deploys
are out of the equation and that makes
it quicker for you to get to resolution
affecting customer impact and let's see
what this looks like in real life so
we're gonna open that same application
and we're gonna go to an example log
line taking a snapshot is as simple as
clicking on the line I'm interested in
see on the right hand side it's waiting
for that snap
to be hit the next time that piece of
code is executed it will gather all the
information about the local variables at
that time to the limit of what's
reasonable from a performance impact
perspective most of the magic of this is
actually in making sure that it does not
impact production making sure that your
conditions which you can add by the way
you can have this snapshot only taken
when you need or the expressions to
print certain variables etc aren't going
to impact your running code and then
it's run in a sandbox to make sure that
it's not actually gonna impact from a
resource perspective or or affect the
bytecode as I mentioned the actual
snapshot is over here on the right hand
side and we can walk the call stack look
through the local variables at any that
are that have been captured if the one
you want isn't captured you can add that
to the expression no problem and that
really gives you that deep level
information of okay well what's
happening in production right now so if
you've ever trouble shot an issue that
you could not reproduce in in product or
sorry you couldn't reproduce in QA
debuggers for you if you've ever
forgotten to add a line of log statement
that you wish you had debuggers for you
so these are the kind of problems we try
to solve and with that being said I'm
gonna hand things over to my colleague
Morgan to talk about profiler thanks
Bryan
so if you attended cloud next last year
you probably would have seen that we
announced act rubber profilers public
beta on stage the keynote and during the
APM breakout since then we've had a ton
of customer success stories of profiler
I'll get into those in a minute but
we're really really proud of how far the
product has come for those who aren't
already aware of profiler stackdriver
profiler is a production code
performance analysis tool
it runs continually on your production
applications with effectively no
performance impact and allows you to
dive into code all the way down to the
function level to see where your code is
being slowed and where it's costing you
resources profiler today works on
applications that use Java node go and
Python we recently added Python support
and as of today profiler is now
generally available which is what we're
really excited that now talk is cheap
and it's difficult to describe some of
these products from from a high-level so
I'm gonna dive into a demo to show you
how we can use profiler to debug
performance problems on a running
production application perfect so this
is one of the instance of the hipster
shop demo that you've probably seen at
many many google talks it's a micro
services application thinks the same
when the Brian was using in his demo
with a whole bunch of services inside of
it written in different languages right
now we're using profiler to inspect the
product catalog service the service I
think is written in go and it's the
database of products inside this fake
e-commerce application so to start
profiler aggregates your performance
data down by the service this product
catalog service I think has about five
instances we reviewing the performance
information across all of those as I
mentioned this is running in production
with effectively no performance impact
which is what separates stackdriver
profiler from most other profiling tools
it runs continually you don't turn it on
for a brief period and then turn it off
again you don't have to turn it on and
freak out that it's going to take down
your system by adding extra load it's
very efficient it's very intuitive
profiler can inspect your the
performance of your code across CPU
performance memory performance and
thread contention today we're gonna look
at CPU you can of course break down your
profiles across zones or different
versions of your app we're not going to
do that today but it's available and
there's some other filters that get to
in a minute by default the
is what you see this is a flame graph if
you've used other profiling tools you're
probably familiar if this on the flame
graph on the horizontal axis we're
showing the performance cost of every
function each box that you see on the
flame graph represents a function in
your code base and so functions that are
taking more horizontal space so like the
one I'm messing over take up more
basically costing you more in terms of
performance and money on the vertical
axis we're showing you the call tree so
in this case we've got search stream
stuff func one dot one that calls handle
stream that calls process unary RPC and
so on and so right away we can tell that
we're burning about half our CPU on this
big stack on the left and if we dive
into it we'll discover that this is
related to JSON serialization and
deserialization probably not something
you want to be spending a lot of time on
on a catalog service that's effectively
a database we'll come back to the in
depth performance of that in a minute
so flame graphs are great for finding
out problems where you have like one big
function in your code base and one big
stack that's consuming a lot of
resources and yeah we've had a lot of
customers who've had got just like these
but profiler is a lot more powerful and
just finding that what I'm gonna open
next is what we call the focus table the
focus table shows us where we're burning
CPU aggregated across all functions you
can sort this by the self consumption
self consumption of a function is the
amount of CPU or memory burned by that
function but not by its children or you
can soda by it sorted by the total
consumption in this case we're gonna
zoom in here on this on the state and
string call which is burning over 5% of
our CPU this brings us to the focus view
so profiler isn't just useful for
finding the performance impact of your
code it's also useful for finding how
your code actually calls itself in
production this focus view has taken
every instance of State and string in
our application and showing us the
different ways that we can get there
from route and how the performance the
performance cost of each of those call
paths this particular case that's not
telling us anything really interesting
what is interesting about focus is that
it'll also show you all the ways out of
that function and by we can observe that
there are none so there's there's no
other functions listed under state and
string that tells us that if we're task
to perform improving the performance of
the service statement string is a good
place to start
because it's burning its own CPU it's
bringing over 5% of the CPU aggregated
across the entire system and finally
it's not it's not spending that time in
its child functions if you want to
optimize it you can optimize that
function on its own one of the other
features of profile that we've had since
the start is coloring a lot of our
customers have told us how aesthetically
pleasing profiler is but then when we
ran a survey our customer base and asked
them what they thought the colors
represented they all told us they had no
idea there's some data that we should
probably change things so starting one
or two weeks ago we added different
coloring modes to profiler I'll show you
those now probably the most useful is
the total coloring total cost coloring
mode which Gendry colors the graph
excuse me REE colors the graph so you
can see where you're burning CPU more
visually this is a bit of an obvious
example these functions were already
taking up half of the horizontal space
but there are a lot of situations where
you can use this like the focused able
to find code that's burning CPU and it's
sprinkled throughout your codebase
finally one of the really interesting
features we have is called weighted
filtering so this example is an app that
in its best case or in this average case
has this JSON deserialization function
that's consuming about half its CPU
that's already egregious just to be
clear but there are you can get many
workloads where the usage or consumption
is somewhat bursty where during normal
periods
you know nothing looks out of like it's
out of whack or in like that it's weird
but you'll have you'll have periods
where your systems under higher stress
there's some sort of kind of background
process running or something else where
suddenly the characterization of the CPU
performance is dramatically different
because profiler is an aggregate
analysis tool it generally wouldn't be
good at catch capturing those which is
why we added waited waited filtering so
what weighted filtering lets me do is
analyze the profiles from periods of
peak consumption what I'm gonna do here
is jump to the CPU profiles captured
when the CPU was at its top 5% of
utilization right here we can see that
that parse catalog function that's
burning our CPU and all of the deep JSON
to serialization functions underneath of
it underneath it are now consuming over
90% of our systems consumption as
opposed to the average case that was
closer to 50% and in fact we can even do
a nice comparison here where we can
compare the weight of the top 5% to the
average and right away we can see
through this new coloring mode that yes
that's in fact exactly where the
increase in in CPU consumption is gone
so profiler is great for improving the
performance of your application like
we've done here it's also a very
powerful cost reduction tool some of our
largest google cloud customers have
reduced their aggregate like their
fleet-wide CPU spend by over 10% of
profiler and there's some who have
achieved even bigger gains in the 20 to
30 percent range it's incredibly
powerful it's something we use inside of
Google across most of our services all
the time to both save money and optimize
the performance of our code as I
mentioned before profilers been
available as a beta for the last year or
so it is now generally available it's
fully supported by Google and we're just
really really happy to see where we're
gonna take this next to that end I'm
gonna invite Nate from outfit 7 to come
on on stage and show us how outfit 7 is
used profiler to reduce their costs and
dramatically improve the performance of
their applications thank you
thanks Morgan hi everyone my name is
Nate and I'm a senior software engineer
working in back-end development team for
outfit seven mobile games and today
let's all imagine that we want to
improve our code performance and make
our operational costs lower and I'm
gonna share with I'm going to share with
you how we do that outfit seven using
App Engine standard and how profiler
makes that process easier for you but
first let me get to know you with outfit
seven and my friend here who will be
joining me throughout this presentation
talking tom
so for outfit seven it all started back
in 2010 with a game called
talking tom and at that time talking tom
turned out to be a worldwide phenomenon
and from that funny mobile game athletes
Evan grew to be one of the fastest
growing family entertainment companies
on the planet and it's not for biggest
publisher of mobile games by Donald so
the outfit it's all about good and
honest fun and that's also the main
reason why talking Tom and friends
franchise is known and loved by fans of
all ages and generations now did you
know that on average every single one of
you has downloaded one of our apps
before and that's because we have more
than 9 billion downloads and you can go
to your any favorite mobile app store
and download one of our 23 free 21
free-to-play mobile games ranging from
top tamagotchi games runner games or
other channels and we also have some
multiplayer games we have around 350
million monthly active users we just put
that number in perspective is like every
US citizen would play our apps on a
regular basis but as you might now
great-looking games are not enough to
deliver all this fun through such a huge
fan base like outfit 7 has behind the
scenes we run complex systems like
real-time game servers and analytic
pipelines they need to scale massively
but today I would like to to be focusing
on the backbone between client devices
and
back in servers so our main mobile
backend runs on App Engine standard and
we were on App Engine standard since the
beginning because it enables you to
focus mainly on application code while
the infrastructure is automatically
managed for you we run more than ten
appengine services for our main database
we are using cloud datastore and for
orchestration test we are using cloud
tasks so let's see how we profile this
app before first we needed to setup a
local development server this was quite
an easy step because it comes out of App
Engine SDK by default so that was quite
an easy step then we needed to define
different profiling scenarios and by
this I mean different application entry
points where your code needs to perform
well and this step is really important
because different entry points to your
application can lead to totally
different execution paths and those
different execution paths target
different aspects of your code and here
we also have to consider both requests
coming from client devices and those
from background running processes then
we needed to populate some production
like data to our local database we did
this through some helper scripts for
data population but as you might know as
time goes on and application code
changes so the data store entities and
you have to you have to manage both
application codes and those scripts that
populate the data otherwise you can do
profiling easy so we had our production
like environment set up on our local
development server now we need to
generate some traffic to it in order to
get some sampling data from for the
profiling stage luckily for us we have a
great integration testing team that has
most of our use cases covered and can
generate quite a good load for us to be
able to profile our application
so the last type was to attach the
profiler some third-party profiler to
the running local development server and
analyze the results so as you can see
this process was really tedious and
there was little to no automation to it
and at the end we could steal me some
use cases because it was just an
imitation of the production environment
and it wasn't actually running on
production so stackdriver profiler made
that process simpler for us you can't
read all of the necessary steps that we
needed to take before and all we are
left to do is to attach tag driver
profiler to our App Engine application
and that is as easy as inserting one
line into App Engine configuration and
deploying it to production so our local
development server gets replaced with
the production server all the data and
traffic is running on production so
there is no imitation of the production
environment and as you can see this
process is so easy that it also makes
our talking tom our friend here a little
bit happier so using stackdriver
profiler we are already able to get rid
some of our out of memory exceptions
those quite often cost some of our batch
processing jobs to fail and using the
profilers dashboard we were able to to
spot the high memory consuming functions
and split them into multiple parts and
got rid of the problem we also did some
performance checks and we reduce the CPU
usage on some of our App Engine services
to around 15% which also made our
operational costs lower but one one
interesting case that I would like to
point out today was of some bad
afternoon deploy so here's the story
we had some late afternoon deploy with a
code that passed old code reviews unit
test integration tests and staging
environment and at the end it still
triggered our alerting system and an
alert was indicated that we had an
increased number of instances running on
some of
App Engine services so we went quickly
to code change history but we we weren't
able to spot any any suspects because
the change in the code was so subtle
that at first glimpse you didn't affect
performance at all
so using you know before the stagger our
profiler we would either revert the full
deploy which would postpone our deployed
features or we would postpone the
investigation of the problem until the
next day which means our our cost would
increase because we would run multiple
App Engine instances but with stag
driver profiler using the feature when
you can compare two versions to each
other
we compared we split fifty percent of
the production draft traffic to the
latest version and to the one before the
broken one and tech Driver profiler
dashboard has this neat feature when you
are comparing
when you are in comparison mode it
highlights the functions that are
performing better or worse with three
different colors and using this feature
we were able to quickly pinpoint the
problem and got rid of Eve in a matter
of half an hour so what's the greatest
profiler value for us the fact that it's
so easy to deploy and that it runs on
production environment this opened quite
a few opportunities for us we are now
able to do code performance checks on a
regular basis which means our codes run
smoother requires less resources to run
and it also affects our cost in a
positive way we also have great insights
to our application because before app
engine standard was really a black box
for us and and the late the last point
that I would like to make is the grabber
profiler is also now a tool to react to
alerts so for example if we if you get
an alert for increased number of
instances running up on App Engine this
means that our cost will be higher if we
get an alert for increased latency this
means bad user experience
and now if we get these alerts we have
new tool to check if the cause of those
alerts is in bad performing code which
we weren't able to do that before at
least not that quickly so I hope that in
this short presentation by me showing
you how out with seven managers good
performance you gain some knowledge and
you can apply it next time that your
code performance suffers thanks thanks
Nate
so what we've shown you today is
Google's stackdriver APM suite and we've
shown you where that exists inside of
stackdriver and where stackdriver exists
inside of Google Cloud first you were
shown stackdriver trace which is a
distributed tracing solution that allows
you to understand how requests and
change the requests propagate through
your services and help you better
understand your services topology then
you saw stackdriver debugger which
effectively lets you set breakpoints
safely in your Production apps finally
we showed you stack driver profiler just
going GA today give you a great customer
story for it before we go to questions I
do want to interject with two things
firstly all of these products will run
on applications running basically
anywhere that includes App Engine
standard compute engine kubernetes
engine it also includes applications
running on premises or on other clouds
our applicate are our platform support
for sector APM is extremely strong
secondly we have very good language
support pricing stack River profilers
currently free debuggers currently free
stack driver trace has paper usage
that's very generous and there's also
very large free tier
[Music]